la traction avant c'était un tour c'est
ce qui m'a permis de prendre un maximum
d'argent avec un minimum de risque et
pour nous et pour les gens l'attrait
principal de l'attraction
c'est de pouvoir s'en servir où on veut
quand on veut comme on veut le moment
qui marque le plus un amateur de
traction je dirais que ce sont les
calais mais les premiers tours de roue
la carrière industrielle d'andré citroën
commence en 1902 par la fabrication
d'engrenages à chevrons puis il
participe à l'effort de guerre en
fabriquant des obus dans son usine du
quai de javel à paris
il croit dans l'expansion de
l'automobile et avant même la fin de la
guerre il décide de reconvertir son
usine pour fabriquer la première voiture
qui portera son nom
c'est la tipp a vendu dès 1919 avec
l'éclairage ce qui est plutôt rare pour
l'époque andré citroën a le sens de
l'innovation
il va aux états unis pour rencontrer
henry ford et s'inspirer de ces
techniques de production
il y aussi un précurseur en matière de
publicité en 1925 le nom de citroën
s'écrit sur toute la hauteur de la tour
eiffel et illumine paris l'initiative
est stupéfiante pour l'époque car elle
nécessite pas moins de deux cent mille
ampoules
en 1927 il fait visiter son usine à
l'héroïque charles lindbergh juste après
sa traversée de l'atlantique en avion en
1925 il est à l'origine de la croisière
noire 8 autochenille et 16 hommes à bord
parcourt le continent africain du nord
au sud
chaque voiture porte un nom scarabée
d'or éléphants latour soleil en marche
escargots et les croissants d'argent
colombes centaure et pégase
en 1931 il lance la croisière jaune pour
traverser le continent asiatique d'est
en ouest pour un groupe et d'ouest en
est pour l'autre toujours avec des autos
chenille à mécanique c4 est et système
qui est grèce
où
l'expédition était rieuse puisqu'il
faudra parfois taille et la montagne
pour se faire un passage et prendre
beaucoup de risques pour passer là où
aucune voiture n'avait jamais roulé
1934 c'est l'année du lancement de la
première révolution citroën
l'attraction sort de lusine de javel un
an plus tard andré citoyenne disparaît
mais les aventures de la traction à
laquelle il a tout donné ne va prendre
fin quand 1957
c'est une voiture qui était extrêmement
novatrice pour l'époque elle avait
concentré sur elle un grand nombre
d'innovations qui n'étaient pas
forcément des progrès technique inconnue
mais elle avait surtout l'atout
principal de réunir sur un seul et même
véhicule
toutes ces solutions nouvelles
l'originalité d'une citroën traction
c'est ce moteur qui entraîne les roues
avant
l'ensemble est en boulonné carrosserie
entièrement en acier sans châssis séparé
du jamais vu en grande série au début
des années 30
l'attraction n'a plus rien à voir avec
la citroën rosalie qui l'a précédée
en supprimant la pour de transmission et
le pont arrière le principe de la
traction avant a permis d'abaisser la
hauteur de l'habitacle et de redessiner
une carrosserie monocoque plus
aérodynamique l'attraction était né
la traction avant maintenant ça nous
paraît évident d'ailleurs tous les
constructeurs ou presque tous
confédération avant elle certains rien
qu'à des tractions avant s'était fait
retirer la voiture par ses roues avant
au lieu de la faire pousser par ces vos
arrières parce que les roues avant
tirant la voiture l'hérault ailleurs
vente ou l'eau les roues avant lui ont
dit d'aller vous pousser une brouette
pour monter un trottoir
vous avez là une propulsion arrière vous
la poussez par l'arrière elle veut pas
monter le strat oil vous mettez dans
l'autre sens et vous tirez la brouette
vous avez une traction avant de vous
tirer dessus
la brouette montrait très bien le
trottoir cette technique là qui a été
appliquée au début de tout dans les
années 1770 parc union par son fardier
c'était un tricycle ce qu'est un trois
roues est une roue avant qui était
motrices directrice avec la chaudière au
dessus on réussit trouvé que c'était la
première fraction un an du monde il
n'avait pas fait exprès
en ligne droite le comportement d'une
traction et d'une propulsion est
semblable
mais en virage la traction avant à une
meilleure tenue de route elle reste
neutre alors que la propulsion cherche à
déraper de l'ariège
ipalle qualité de cette voiture c'est sa
fiabilité mais un petit peu dans tous
les domaines tenue de route qui n'est
jamais prise en défaut les conception
mécanique qui fait que rares sont les
pannes qui ont bien entendu s'agit d'un
objet on est anormal de roulage
il faut quand même parler de choses
réalistes et d'une sécurité d'emploi une
sécurité de fonctionnement et en plus
des volumes intérieurs qui permettent de
voyager confortablement avec les bagages
que l'on souhaite et les personnes
évidemment qui s'y rattachent
alors on dit qu'elle a des défauts
handica direction et lourdes traction
avant comme son nom l'indiqué tous mes
gros à valence est fait pour être tourné
ils écrivent d'actes pour pur un créneau
on est un petit peu en bd mais des
claude geay roule ça se conduit très
facilement par gras je ne lui trouve pas
que des faux voilà et même pas surtout
pas le défaut de lenteur ou là où la
possibilité de s'inscrire dans un trafic
routier quels qu'ils soient ses défauts
qui n'en était pas vraiment à l'époque
mais qui pourraient être des défauts
maintenant sont effectivement une boîte
trois vitesses encore que la parade été
récemment trouvé une petite en selle à
la chauffe mais surtout pour les six
cylindres essentiellement aussi une
direction un peu dur
et un rayon de braquage quand même
nettement plus adapté aux circulations
contemporaine pour le reste les qualités
bon c'est toujours la gouttière et la
reine de la route
peut-être qu'elle était considéré dans
les années 50 ça se profile parfaitement
bien dans le top des circulations
contemporaine
c'est plus agréable sur route nationale
que sur autoroute pas de réel problème
pas très loin de réels problèmes
d'utilisation qualité et agrément en
fonction de ce qu était semi technologie
quand il était sorti donc une voiture
fiable qui ferait bien qui tient très
bien la route et parfois mieux sa faible
hauteur
andré citroën qui était très souvent aux
états unis et admirateur de la technique
et sur toute la construction en série
américaine donc renault s'était inspiré
au contact de ford
il a pensé beaucoup à une traction avant
et à tout hasard il a acheté une licence
de juin pour traction avant c'est à dire
c'est la partie qui relie le moteur aux
roues motrices pendant ce temps là et
même avant andré lefebvre et gabriel
voisin avait pensé à une traction avant
et ils l'ont étudié et puis le voisin
hélas été encore une fois en faillite ça
lui est arrivé plusieurs fois dans sa
vie il la vit à le faire dans le milieu
il faut qu'ils cherchent du boulot parce
que moi je peux plus tu employés il se
fait embaucher par louis renault
et puis là il en vient à a déposé son
brevet avec tous les plans tous les
dessins qui elle est faite voisin de la
traction avant alors la renault a éclaté
de rire en lisant notre action a donc
c'est tout
mais vingt mètres renaud nour nous nous
ferons des véhicules à traction avant
mais c'est un non sens c'est pas viable
le faire où est parti en claquant la
porte et là il est allé chez citroën
c'était en 1932 suite rennes qui était
lui avec l'idée sous jacente d'une
traction allemand voilà qui est un homme
qui lui apporte les plats qui semblait
savoir ce qu'il disait arrive ensuite
rendu au tchad a peur ok allez on fait
une traction et c'est là ça a été
l'origine de la traction avant
cette voiture a continué d'évoluer
jusqu'à la finition seulement entre le
point de départ et le point où la
voiture a été présenté aux
concessionnaires et enroulée il a fallu
à peu près comment à peine
toutes les factions des concessionnaires
comment allons nous faire pour monde sa
rupture très basse enfin et les premiers
modèles sortent avec des joints tracas
de l'ingénieur eyewear il avait fait un
joint moins cher plus facile à monter en
une série se joint à a été un désastre
il arrivait que des traction avant
citroën premier modèle dans les mains
des premiers clients et ça c'était
important et durera quatre ou cinq cents
kilomètres alors ça l'effet boule de
neige oui la dhr action avant ça vaut
rien et c'est un discrédit jeté sur la
traction avant la bresse emboîtent le
pas quelquefois la presse a raison là
aussi élevé raison bien latérite
il voit là que la voiture est condamné
citroën qui était endetté jusqu'aux
sourcils commencer à se poser des
questions mais il était trop tard
la traction avant avait fait perdre trop
d'argent
ainsi trois afghans n'avaient pas
beaucoup et il appelle au secours il est
mis en faillite par un artisan
c'est curieux et il est repris par
michelin était son principal créancier
il est me flingue pierre boulanger et
bien messieurs
rim est un spécialiste sur la traction
avant et la hat ans c'était avec des
modifications peu importants
elle est viable alors on l'a
quand débute la production de la citroën
traction sept chevaux andré citroën a
une idée géniale pour prouver la
solidité de la carrosserie lancer une
traction du haut d'une falaise de 8 m
sous l'oeil du cinématographe
le film ne montrera pas la vitre arrière
cassée mais on constate que les portes
s'ouvrent encore et apparemment la
traction n'a pas trop souffert
puisqu'elle va repartir par ses propres
moyens
alors lors de son lancement l'attraction
les jusqu en un modèle l'a77 ce vous qui
évolue aux neuf chevaux et citroën
voulait par là en faire une voiture de
catégorie moyenne assez populaire suite
elle évolué en chevaux culturellement en
quinze chevaux ce qui fait qu'avec les
différents types de carrosserie que ça
permettait de décliner des berlines des
familiales des commercial des cabriolets
découper elle pouvait toucher un grand
nombre d'acheteurs
le grand regret que l'on peut formuler à
la marque citroën et +10 train à
l'époque à la marque citroën
d'abord quand même laisser produire
pendant si longtemps une voiture qui
était quand même très spartiate au point
de vue aménagement intérieur il faut
reconnaître que ces tableaux de bord
verticale en taule avec juste quelques
boutons indispensable c'était quand même
un petit peu dit enfin bon on lui
pardonne tellement
toute la france va rouler en traction
après les combattants c'est la france
libre qui lui fait confiance
même la police va utiliser des tractions
équipe et tout spécialement d'une
volumineuse radio dans le coffre
la calandre étant souvent modifié pour
prendre une forme bombée afin d'y loger
la sirène la pègre choisi aussi
l'attraction pour ses qualités le gang
des tractions n'est pas une légende
rené girard y est alias rené la canne
est l'un des survivants de ces gentlemen
cambrioleurs et en appelle rené la canne
en bois la la la la
voilà le jeu chez leurs seulement
maintenant je suis invalide avec tout
les trucs que j'ai dit que les fruits
qui m'ont tiré dessus pour davantage
qu'on avait nous que j'avais c'est que
on les achetait les voitures dont les
volets faut ça commençait par les 11 et
puis quand je me suis aperçu que elle
démarrait pas tellement bien c est passé
à prix rapide
on a acheté des 15 parce que comme on
les hait trafic et comme on mettait en
surface et la culasse de carburateur ça
des galères cet ingénieur c'est citroën
qui voulait bien nous les trafics et et
puis ils avaient déposé des brevets n'a
rien voulu les vendre citroën puis
citroën les a pas assez peu encore
besoin est brun ou du coup nous les
avants du coup ça nous intéressait et
puis pour pour amortir les vrais c'est
là qu'on a fait le on s'est arrêté
devant un beau château vérifia tôt et
daladier
alors là on on a pitié on a fait ouvrir
le coffre à dallas dire et c'est là
qu'ils avaient le cou des fameuses
enveloppes que ça avait défrayé la
chronique
parce qu'il y avait une femme de chambre
elle a dit non les ongles plat c'est
notre pays
enfin jugé alors je devrai donner à
chacune de roubles
ah bah tout le monde avait les tractions
c'était la voiture de l'époque les
industriels tout ça les cinéastes
même les artistes ils avaient des
tractions avec chauffeur bien sûr et
tout c'était des voitures excessivement
sur bon ils en font plus comme ça je
crois pour l'attraction le canton quand
je me suis avaler l'hôpital criminelle
de villejuif
c'était une traction qui nous attendait
une 15e mais comme j'étais avec evil 2
800 il avait des grenades soucier
belgique et 6 1 màj saisi grenade eut
dit vous êtes fond du nom josé on s'est
parlé hier
by me dire au nez si tu veux arrêter lui
et je me suis arrêté au métro ils m'ont
arrêté au métro liberté sas avait fait
ça avait fait un vrai tollé à l'époque
sans savoir un la traction avant c'était
un tour c'est ce qui m'a permis de
prendre un maximum d'argent avec un
minimum de risque et pour nous et pour
les gens c'est tout que c'est la
conclusion les liens ci avait pas eu la
traction sais rien oh non j'avais essayé
un moment donné de leyde gros soleil
pendant sa tient pas
dans l'attraction c'est la voiture qui
m'a permis de prendre un maximum
d'argent avec un minimum de risque un
minimum de risque pour tout le monde
sous non c'était bien embassies a pas eu
d'effraction peut-être que petit n'y
aurait pas eu de grandes attractions
heures c'est un peu près sûr traction
avant police après c'est tout quoi
31 juillet 1957 date importante pour les
usines citroën
les vétérans des chaînes de javel
entourent d'un soin tout particulier la
dernière 11e votre action avant
classiques dont on fête aujourd'hui la
sortie
ils l'ont aussi décoré d'un bouquet
tricolore pour célébrer gaiement cette
étape de leur carrière et le plus âgé
d'entre eux a eu l'honneur de frapper
lui même le dernier numéro de la série
son heureux propriétaire qui dut
l'acquérir de haute lutte contre des
centaines d'amateurs passionnés reçoit
les félicitations d'un directeur qui en
1934 assister au lancement commercial du
modèle et la dernière fraction avant
classique va maintenant quitté son
berceau de sa belle
mais détail symbolique au moment de
sortir de l' usine
elle marque un temps d'arrêt pour les
fait passer la traction avant de
l'avenir l'attraction ont été
construites tous modèles confondus lé 7
11 et 15 entre 1934 et 1957 à plus de
750 mille exemplaires avec revanche est
exact c'est difficile à définir mais ce
que l'on sait moins c'est qu'elle a été
construite dans deux filiales de citroën
d'abord en belgique
zinn de forest à côté de bruxelles et en
grande bretagne suisse là où à côté de
londres
alors ces deux productions sont était
intéressante
il ya quelques trente et un mille
exemplaires d'âge et environ 25000
exemplaires britannique
c'est de nature en fête qui n'a jamais
vraiment disparu du paysage automobile
vers la fin des années 60 si on avait
encore beaucoup qui roulait en usage
courant et c'est le moment où les
premiers collectionneurs des gens de ma
génération en fait ont commencé à s'y
intéresser à rouler avec
bon elle était déjà peut-être un petit
peu relégué considéré voter ancien
démodé mais elle est encore très
présente et c'est une voiture qui était
facile à utiliser et qui donnait envie à
des jeunes gens en quête d'une certaine
originalité de vouloir rouler
différemment
alors on dit une traction avant mais en
fait ce sont des tractions temps le
modèle a été déclinée au modèle de base
dans différents types de carrosserie
alors le dessin original c'est celui de
la sete dont la carrosserie a très vite
servi à celui de la rose légère la 7
chevaux c'est une très jolie petite
chose entre guillemets
nikki est déjà un petit peu moins
roulant que l'attraction classique sous
l'image conventionnelle qu'on en est
revenu car le train avant des différents
donc la conduite est plus spécial le
véhicule était moins rapide
moi moi agréable moins conformes aux
standards actuels
cette voiture venait d'un particulier
qui s'appelait monsieur parquet sucy en
brie et qui avait commencé une
restauration à son goût ont eux c'était
tout satisfaisant au niveau de
l'authenticité de cette veille de cette
28e
dans le gers et ce modèle là c'est le
dessin vraiment originale de traction on
la reconnaît à son allure fine d'une
voiture à ses désirs comme son nom l
indique qu' reconnaissable à sa calandre
galbées un petit peu en creux voiture de
lure cavalière et dynamique
alors il est venu très vite en 11
normales normal qui reprend le même
principe du moteur katsina sur une
carrosserie beaucoup plus grosses plus
logeable qui est reconnaissable donc au
volume de la caisse et ensuite à la
calandre à mazan qui est cette fois-ci
bombay qui n'est plus en retrait qui est
bombé vers l'avant alors lance normale
et une allure plus lourde plus assises
d'une voiture déjà un peu plus cossus
plus logeable larmont d'un seul modèle
idéal qu'ils soient légers
normal c'est la motorisation de la
voiture en quelques cotes important pour
mon grand frère
les
on va vers la 15 chevaux qui est donc le
haut de gamme qui reprend la carrosserie
aux plus grosses avec un capot beaucoup
plus longs pour loger le moteur 6
cylindres et la calandre bombay qui
cette fois ci est en avant des phares
alors là 15 chevaux
donc le modèle le plus puissant de la
gamme développée autour d'un moteur six
cylindres qui fait presque 3 litres de
cylindrée voyez car comme on dit aux
bestiaux est ce une voiture
extraordinaire à conduire qui a beaucoup
de personnalité un caractère assez
animal mais qui laisse de grands
souvenirs de route l'a 15 où on
l'appelait la reine de la route celle ci
si l'un des moteurs 4 cylindres plus
deux autres cylindres hélas le roulage
en 15 mois
ben le vent je trouve que d'abord la
voiture consomme
ensuite elle est beaucoup plus lourde
que la rose et la baie lorsque l'on
roule vite en 15 ans peut parfois il
ren sauter dans champs parce que ça
attire tout droit c'est trop lourd de la
vente à fric frac
voilà je suis monsieur toucherait
collectionneurs de citroën j'ai bien sûr
des c4 et des c6 donc cette voiture et
celle de monsieur petit personnel
on peut dire on voit ici sur les jeux
supposé trop pour les fanions point de
vue moteur on peut dire qu'il ya ici une
pipe à air un peu spécifique
là il ya une sirène donc on peut
remarquer ici les numéros de châssis
normalement pas répertoriés chez citroën
comme cette voiture en réalité a été
immatriculée en décembre 1958
bien sûr on peut voir aussi à
l'intérieur
arrières débouchés à air de chauffage à
l'avant bien sûr y en a pas parce que
les chauffeurs n'y avait pas doit bien
sûr à l'arrêt on peut regarder dans le
coffre
une pompe à essence spéciale pour amener
les sens bien sûr en direct
alors la 22è 5000 une réalité tout
d'abord c'est une réalité
andré citroën voulait que le haut de
gamme de la série de tractions soit un
moteur v8
il était construit on estime à près une
douzaine de modèles en différents types
de carrosseries berline limousine et
cabriolets et coupés
on les connaît avec certitude parce
qu'elles ont été photographiés il y en a
trois d'entre elles qui ont été exposés
au salon de l'auto d'octobre 934 et puis
lorsque michelin a racheté citroën
ils ont demandé qu'on arrête alors
maintenant le mythe autour de cela tout
le monde rêve de retrouver une 22 alors
on peut croire par exemple je fais un
grand manufacturier de pneumatiques
français y en ait une qui soit restée là
bas qui échappe et la destruction qui
seront encore en train de sommeil et
dans le fond ni dans l'obscur
il
voilà je suis philippe sauret vous êtes
ici dans mes ateliers jeunes arrivés au
volant d'une 15,6 1951 derrière vous
avez une chose normale de 1955 une
hausse légère de 1938 et une super
traction rosengart qui utilisaient la
mécanique de citroën traction
alors mon travail consiste à faire de la
restauration de l'entretien de la
réparation sur les tractions partir
départ comme celle ci c'est inutile on
en fera toujours une belle voiture mais
jamais une bonne voiture vaut mieux
partir sur des bases d'origine comme ces
voitures-là cette voiture on va qui est
dans son état d'origine
on va la remettre en configuration
sortie du sinn le mieux qu'on peut avec
les moyens qu'on aura un autre
disposition actuellement le principe de
restauration de la traction
ce n'est pas un principe spécifique
c'est exactement l'application d'un plan
un stéréotype en fonction de l'état dans
lequel on trouve le véhicule dans le
conflit ça commence tout de suite par
les phrases que les caoutchoucs ont
toujours sécher les pneumatiques tout ce
qu'est caoutchouc c'est à balancer et
refaire après on s'attaque aux côtés coq
il faut toujours repartir sur une base
saine si elle n'est pas saine on change
les pour plancher en charge des bas de
caisse on fabrique ce qui manque et
ensuite on continue avec la mécanique
complète moteur voix tendre royal d
échappement le ensuite la tôlerie et
quand tout ce que ça est fini la
peinture et enfin en dernier la sellerie
tu sais qu'il est conseillé de faire en
plusieurs étapes parce que sinon la
dépense est assez à ses somptueuses quel
que soit le modèle mais parce que c'est
une traction
c'est ça s'applique à tous
à tout véhicule teddy depuis seule la
durée de vie d'un moteur de traction 4
cylindres d'environ 80 à 100 mille
kilomètres un moteur six cylindres comme
celui ci est d'environ 100 120 mille km
1 cette voiture qui est une 15,6 1951
actuellement à vendre
nous allons agir sur le pot
d'échappement qui est à remplacer une
mise au point un moteur la réfection des
freins et cette voiture pourra passer un
contrôle technique avec brio ensuite au
propriétaire futur de l'enjoliver de
l'améliorer de prévoir éventuellement la
réfection de la peinture et des chromes
voilà une des améliorations possibles
que l'on peut effectuer sur les
tractions le montage d'une boîte 4
vitesses on y monte aussi des filtres à
huile sur les moteurs on peut améliorer
le système électrique on peut les
montées avec des circuits électriques 12
volts on peut améliorer le système de
freinage par un kit de centrage de
garniture
l'autre amélioration possible et la
transformation des culasses pour pouvoir
rouler à l'essence sans plomb alors le
coût d'entretien d'une traction est
fonction de la façon dont elle a été
restaurée et préparer à son utilisation
courante ou occasionnels une voiture
parfaitement restauré dans les règles de
l'art et patron c'est possible les prix
de vente
secondes et vitesse ça permet de rouler
normalement
bon celui qui fera trente mille
kilomètres par an effectivement rab
usure plus rapidement mais les organes
de sécurité les organes d'usure se
remplace facilement donc un coût
d'utilisation très raisonnable très
voisin de ce que coûte une voiture
moderne aux récentes avec la traction il
ya un phénomène est indispensable de vos
kessé le domaine de la collection c'est
actuellement une voiture qui est
certainement la plus collectionner en
france et même dans beaucoup d'autres
pays du monde
la version la plus prisée des
collectionneurs cvo en tout des biens le
cabriolet ce qu'on appelait le roadster
c'est pas la plus rare c'est la plus
appréciée des voitures mythiques
cabriolet en tant que tel point que le
cabriolet on oublie les couper donc il
faut cabriolet tollé qui ont été
fabriquées
à moins de 1000 exemplaires pour que les
cabriolets y en a eu quatre mille et
quelques les carrosseries spéciale les
découvrable très recherchée mais peu
nombreuses et souvent méconnu le mythe
la reine de la route la 15e soit d'avant
guerre d'après guerre où oléopneumatique
beaucoup de succès recherché
ce sont là dix ans les modèles les plus
appréciés en oubliant la femme de votre
rêve it
qui apparemment n'existe plus le modèle
le plus rare en fait n'est pas celui
qu'on croit
il est très très difficile de trouver
une 15 d'avant-guerre et au niveau du
nombre d'exemplaires produits
effectivement après on tombe sur l'a15
oléopneumatique des années 54 55 qui
préfigurait la ds avec sa suspension
hydraulique 10 à 15 % des propriétaires
de traction avant appartiennent à des
clubs
un huitième des clubs multimarques
donc là on ne sait pas trop combien de
voitures existent par l'entremise de ces
clubs au niveau des clauses spécifiques
traction il y en a 25 environ en france
donc on peut estimer en france un parc
automobile roulant ou pouvant l'être à
environ quinze vingt mille voitures à
peine 3% de la production française qui
s'est fait à hauteur d'environ 67 cents
mille voitures
il y en a eu à peu près 45 milles à
l'étranger par contre hors de france
on a fait des estimations assez serré on
estime le parc à huit et dix mille
voitures donc tous confondus france
étrangers on peut tabler sur 25 à 30 32
mille voitures
alors au niveau des amateurs
propriétaire de traction j'ai pas le
terme de collectionneurs parce que ça
correspond à une l'idée de chiffres qui
ne correspond pas à ce que nous sommes
toutes les classes sociales possible
chez nous au niveau des collectionneurs
toutes les classes sociales toutes aux
niveaux sociaux et toutes les
générations
on a des membres de 19 ans et des
membres que je qualifierais quasiment du
quatrième âge qui les ont achetés
d'origine est conservée qui les ont
racheté à leur retraite donc on a un
panel très très très très large de
propriétaires de traction avant et ce ne
sont pas les plus riches qui ont les
plus chers ou les plus belles ce qui a
un petit peu poussé ce félin de
collection c'est la diversité du modèle
la déclinaison des modèles
en fait quand on est en légère on a
souvent envie d'avoir le modèle lance
normal puis de compléter la série par
une 15 ans suit il ya les familiales qui
s'impose et c'est donc un avis de fait
d'engranger si on a la place quatre ou
cinq traction et le mouvement est parti
passer un peu le phénomène que j'ai
suivi et puis surtout ce qui était un
moyen de rencontre extraordinaire parce
qu'au-delà de la collection ces deux
rencontres humaines fantastique et ça
qu'ils sont encore plus éternel pc
voiture un club s'est créé en 68 en
l'occurrence c'est le nôtre l'attraction
universelle et très vite les
propriétaires de berlines ont demandé à
en faire partie donc le club en 69 70
s'est lancé dans tous les types de
traction c'est à dire que tout le monde
pouvait adhérer avec tous les modèles de
pression vous avez paraissant singles
club qui est le rassemblement de
propriétaires et d'amateurs de traction
pour les faire rouler les restaurer les
entretenir
alors
à ce niveau là vous avez des clubs qui
permettent de se promener vous avez des
clubs régionaux plus important est
structuré qui permettront aux
propriétaires de ces voitures de
bénéficier de bons conseils d'avoir sous
la main l'échelon régional de bons
professionnels pour entretenir et
restaurer aider à trouver des pièces et
vous avez le club d'obédience nationale
qui lui fabrique des pièces qui permet
de trouver des professionnels très
compétents qui possède la revue les
conseils techniques et qui par son son
âge a vu passer des milliers de membres
qui tous ont pu entretenir et faire
rouler des voitures donc on classifie
les clubs en fonction de ce qu'ils
apportent des clubs bien structurés
permettront de rouler à moyen et à long
terme entre fabricants parfois des
pièces que les marchands ne font pas
c'est donc là la survie des clubs est
également la survie des propriétaires
leurs actions
faire le tour du monde avec deux
tractions 11 chevaux c'est le pari que
se sont fixé quatre français en 1988
eric m'assieds yann régniau luc marescot
étoffe hermenier un voyage qui leur fera
parcourir 70 mille kilomètres sur cinq
continents pendant cinq cent soixante
quatre jours
les deux tractions chrome et cambouis or
ont parfois du mal à se frayer un chemin
mais elles ne connaîtront que 58 panne
avant de revoir paris
à
principal de l'attraction c'est de
pouvoir s'en servir
où on veut quand on veut comme on veut
en tout en toute sécurité
et puis en tout agrément c'est ça la
traction s'est pas c'est pas un objet de
culte c'est pas mythique c'est une
excellente voiture il y en a eu dans
toutes les familles
un don plus le tente je ne sais pour un
grand p a une grand mère un père avait
la même année etc etc
alors en cas de problème là on vient de
voir que tout roulait en cas de problème
qu'est ce qui se passe la voiture
s'arrête dans la voiture s'arrête
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on peut pas
faire grand chose si on est parti un peu
trop vite et un peu trop au hasard il
faut tout de même dans nos petites
promenades qu'on emmène en traction ou
en autre chose
ce que j'appellerais un petit lot de
bord un petit magasin portable pour
pallier aux déficiences qui peuvent se
produire alors vous pouvez admirer ici
présent le l'archétype de ce que de ce
que nous emmenons promenade à savoir une
pochette moteur complète avec tous les
joints qui peuvent servir à pallier un
ennui une courroie car les d'un type
spécifique on ne la trouve pas dans le
commerce facilement encore moins à
l'étranger
une paire de durite de radiateur parce
que pourquoi pas une bobine car c'est du
6 volts et on trouve pas facilement vinh
d'allumage un régulateur de tension de
charges toujours ainsi volts pour le bon
fonctionnement de la dynamo un allumeur
complet ou au minimum une tête
d'allumeur avec le rotor toujours parce
que c'est spécifique
bon là bien entendu ses cris sont les
outils de la voiture avec une petite
planche est pour pâques le cri s'enfonce
dans le dans la gadoue et puis voilà ce
qu'on appelle nous une boîte un miracle
avec tout ce qui peut nous manquer tout
ce qu'on peut tout ce dont on peut avoir
besoin tout ce qui pose l'abîmé on n'en
mène pas une voiture en double mais on
emmène quand même quelques petites
quelques petites choses qui nous
permettent de continuer le cours du
voyage tranquillement
sans resté bloqué deux trois jours à
l'hôtel en attendant d'avoir une pièce
qui par chronopost qui part dépannage
qui bien entendu par le biais note club
autrement vont se poser surtout quand on
se promène donc voilà si besoin s'en
faisait sentir un petit coup de
téléphone à un membre du club
et là on nous envoie un cardan à ceci ou
cela mais en général on se promène avec
ça et puis ça suffit largement
non
parmi tous les raids en rallyes
internationaux auxquels j'ai participés
où j'ai contribué que j'ai contribué à
organiser
incontestablement le plus le plus
sympathique qui a été leur aide franco
acadiens en 88 vous nous sommes qui nous
a permis d'aller d'acqua di et du québec
jusqu'en louisiane
un temps fort de la voiture ancienne
avec une convivialité dans le cadre du
proco phonie hyper présente sur le
continent américain
ça c'est notre bébé on organisait tout
seul on l'a enfantée dans la douleur
mais le résultat était au delà de nos
espérances
un autre raid international fort ça a
été le paris moscou en 1984 avec 132
traction avec l'autorisation de pénétrer
en russie le jour du départ à paris donc
on était très ambitieux 350 personnes
attendaient et donc on a fait dix mille
kilomètres en quatre semaines pour se
retrouver dans la russie soviétique de
pêche nef ont fait sans parler mon grade
l'époque et on séjourne en deux jours à
moscou
ça a été un moment très fort avec le
côté pesant de ce qu'était le contexte
politique de l'époque que ce soit en
russie ou en pologne ou en allemagne de
l'est
nous n'avons pas eu de réel problème
d'organisation pour ce raid de l'est
dans la mesure où à partir de
l'autorisation de pénétrer en territoire
soviétique
on avait je dirais pas les coudées
franches mais la possibilité de faire un
peu ce que l'on voulait parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas maîtriser 350 personnes si
facilement c'est donc d'emblée il
acceptait qu'il y ait éventuellement
quelques dérives en matière de
fréquentation des routes est vraiment
très très fort et les souvenirs
le dernier périple en date vécue par des
tractions a eu lieu en 1998 c'est le
trac barden dix raids de trois semaines
et de 5000 kilomètres à travers
l'australie
organisé par eric m'assieds celui qui
avait conçu le tour du monde en traction
dix ans auparavant
quarante traction était au départ toutes
venues d'europe 40 est à l'arrivée
il se murmure déjà qu'un trackpad 1,10
aura lieu en l'an 2000 le siècle
changent mais les tractions sont
toujours là
tous